we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P and this caller has a
question about the impact that the train
derailment may have on the 2024 election
hey David so uh the situation is passing
Ohio
what do you think the political
ramifications will be for 2024 does this
make it harder for Democrats to win Ohio
because we are in power right now and
whatever happens
will get blamed on on Democrats or the
lack of things that are going on now do
you think that it'll have political
ramifications for 2024 thanks bye you
know I really don't I really don't now
there's the truth and there's what you
can spin the truth is that I don't know
why Democrats would be blamed for the
train derailment given that what
happened is that as far as we know right
now
the rail company
did not install HotBox detectors as
close together as they are recommended
and as a result they missed that the
train fire appeared to have started 20
miles out of East Palestine that is
nothing directly to do with Democrats
specifically It generally has to do with
under regulation the governor of Ohio is
a republican Ohio is basically run by
Republicans but it also isn't clear that
it's necessarily an Ohio thing but the
the truth of the matter is it would be
really weird to blame certainly Biden if
he's the Democratic candidate in 2024
for the train derailment train
derailments are sadly quite common
fortunately they've also declined in
frequency over time now Ohio hasn't gone
for Democrats since uh 2012 and 2008 in
2016 Trump won Ohio and won the
presidency in 2020 Trump won Ohio but
lost the presidency
I don't believe that the Ohio 2024
results are going to hinge on the train
derailment in particular
not only because it doesn't make sense
that they would but in particular
because voters have a relatively short
memory and uh I just don't think it's
going to be something Ohio voters are
going to decide on uh but if you
disagree with me let me know in the
comments we have a fantastic bonus show
for you today we're going to talk about
Putin bailing on the new start treaty we
are going to talk about critics
rejecting changes to Roald Dahl's books
as censorship and I will tell you my
position on that and we will talk a
little bit about project Veritas founder
James O'Keefe out at his organization
partially because of multiple harassment
claims as I understand it all of those
stories and more will be on today's
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money sure everybody else
that makes money to find themselves is
bad yeah help us make a little money on
the bonus show we call it funding
Independent Media you can sign up at
joinpakman.com this gets you instant
access to the bonus show it funds all
all of the work we do and you get The
Daily Show without commercials hours
before everybody else you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the discount
code 24
starts now and boy has it ever I look
forward to seeing you on today's bonus
show